votre présence directeur du domaine
renseignement anticipation et stratégie
d'influence à l'Institut de recherche
stratégique de l'école militaire l'IRCEM
associant universitaire et militaire
l'ircelles et l'organisme de recherche
stratégique du ministère des armées ces
études contribuent au renforcement du
lien entre la défense et la recherche
stratégique apporte leur concours à
l'enseignement militaire supérieur et
soutiennent le rayonnement de la pensée
stratégique française au niveau national
et international
spécialiste de la Chine vous avez
notamment été chercheur associé à
l'antenne franco-chinoise de sciences
humaines et sociales de l'université
kingway
à Pékin en octobre 2021 vous avez publié
avec Jean-Baptiste Jean genviller un
rapport remarqué de l'IRCEM sur les
opérations de l'influence chinoise
qualifiant la phase actuelle de latitude
chinoise de moments machiavelliens
vous y décrivez Tik Tok je cite comme
une plateforme surveillée et censurée
utiliser comme outil de propagande par
le Parti communiste chinois soulignant
les liens des dirigeants de by dance
avec Pékin le rapport cité plusieurs
exemples de contenus censurés sur
l'application en Chine et à
l'international mais aussi de contenu
ajouté par des comptes fantômes gérés
par des employés de l'entreprise alors
que les interdictions d'utilisation de
Tik Tok pour les élus ou les
fonctionnaires se multiplient vous
pourrez nous éclairer sur la réalité de
la dépendance de cette entreprise et de
sa société mère bike dance à l'égard du
pouvoir chinois donc après de les
premières auditions plutôt axées sur les
aspects techniques de nous permettre de
d'élargir le champ et de se poser la
question des la question des contenus et
encore merci d'être là je me dois de
rappeler que cette audition est captée
et retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et avant de vous laisser la parole
pour un exposé liminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes ici si ça vous convient mais
mon meilleur a un jeu de
questions-réponses après qui vous
permettra de préciser les choses je vais
donc procéder au formalité d'usage pour
les commissions d'enquête et je dois
ainsi vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du code
pénal et je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
merci beaucoup monsieur Charron donc
nous vous écoutons pour votre exposé
luminaire et puis ensuite on passera aux
questions on se donne une petite heure
écart au globale voilà
[Musique]
donc je suis un spécialiste de la Chine
et pas spécialiste des aspects
techniques de la désinformation donc
qu'il s'agisse de des informations enfin
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
donc je vais surtout essayer de vous
éclairer sur sur le contenu et comment
comment d'une manière générale les
pratiques
informationsnelles chinoises se
déploient que ce soit sur Tik Tok ou
d'autres plateformes parce que le
problème est pas fondamentalement
différent finalement
ce qu'il faut peut-être commencer par
rappeler c'est que
l'application Tik Tok ne recueille pas
davantage de renseignements sur ces
utilisateurs que d'autres applications
du même type et là c'est ce que j'ai pu
lire parce que moi je suis spécialiste
de ces questions là mais moins que
facebook même par exemple
donc la question c'est pas tant
finalement en tout cas c'est pas
seulement la question de la quantité de
données ou la nature des données qui
peuvent être collectées par Tik Tok et
inhiné par bit dance donc ça la maison
mère chinoise mais plutôt la nature du
régime politique entre les mains duquel
c'est informations pour arriver un
régime autoritaire s'il en est le régime
chinois
une autre distinction peut-être
importante et celle de la nature des
utilisateurs il y a sans doute une
distinction à faire entre
je n'en serais après mais il y a quand
même une à faire entre des utilisateurs
dont les activités professionnelles
représentent un intérêt pour la Chine et
donc peuvent constituer des cibles du
Parti communiste chinois et les
utilisateurs disons lambda qui
n'ont pas de représentent pas en tant
que tel d'intérêt pour les PCC même
s'ils peuvent faire l'objet
collectivement
d'opérations de désinformation ou
d'influence menées par le parti
donc ce que je vous propose c'est de
passer en revue un certain nombre de
points durs de questions qui
émergent dans les dans les médias
d'activités disons inquiétantes à tout
le moins de la part de Tik Tok
c'est pas exhaustif mais ça permet de
illustrer en quoi c'est un problème en
quoi l'application peut poser problème
d'abord il y a eu un certain nombre de
révélations c'est c'est trois dernières
années
a commencé par une opération
d'espionnage
de contrôle des suivis deux journalistes
par
by dance
cette affaire a été révélée par
différents médias à la suite
d'enregistrement audio qui ont fuité
depuis
Tik Tok c'est à peu près 80 heures
d'enregistrement qui ont été ainsi
diffusés et qui ont été analysés par par
les médias notamment qui ont travaillé
sur sur cette question notamment
BuzzFeed et qui ont montré que
les un certain nombre de un certain
nombre d'utilisateurs américains
les données disons d'un certain nombre
d'utilisateurs américains étaient entre
les mains
d'utilisateurs de by dance donc de
personnel de l'entreprise by dance en
Chine et non pas de personnel de Tik Tok
ailleurs hors de Chine or toute la la
défense de Tik Tok qui est bien illustré
par le projet que l'entreprise a mis en
place récemment un projet Texas donc de
stockage des données utilisateurs
notamment aux États-Unis
et à Singapour donc en dehors de Chine
en tout cas
cette affaire a montré que cela n'était
pas vrai donc puisque des membres de by
dance affirmait eux-mêmes dans ses
enregistrements qu'ils avaient accès aux
données
ces premières informations étaient un
point de départ d'enquête menée par
différents médias
journaux d'investigation américain et
qui ont révélé qu'en fait
en partie une partie disons des
Américains qui avaient été suivis
par bidens étaient des journalistes qui
s'intéressaient à Tik Tok
et ce qui est intéressé particulièrement
bidens c'était de savoir s'il ne pouvait
pas croiser les données de
géolocalisation de ces journalistes avec
des employés de Tik Tok pour identifier
qui était responsable des fuites au sein
de la société donc qui avait parlé
aujourd'hui donc c'est ça qui est
intéressé essentiellement dans cette
affaire en tout cas
l'entreprise l'entreprise chinoise
donc d'une manière générale
on peut pas
accorder beaucoup de crédit
à Tik Tok quand l'entreprise nous dit
que les données restent aux États-Unis
ou en tout cas hors de Chine que la
frontière entre bydens et Tik Tok et
étanche et qu'aucune donnée ne peut être
exploité par la partie chinoise de
de du groupe
deuxième problème que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure également c'est celui de
la censure donc la censure sur les
contenus Tik Tok
alors bien sûr peut-être une première
remarque pour nuancer un petit peu
la censure dont on parle sur Tik Tok n'a
rien à voir avec la censure qui existe
sur les autres sur les réseaux sociaux
chinois en Chine et a commencé par
drawing qui est donc la version chinoise
de Tik Tok où là la censure est complète
il y a un contrôle total de
l'information dans le cas de Tik Tok
c'est différent c'est plus comparable à
ce qu'on peut voir sur Facebook sur
Instagram sur Twitter aussi que les
Chinois ont investi à l'image des russes
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant avec des opérations de plus
en plus nombreuses et de plus en plus
sophistiqué
donc un certain nombre de cas pour
illustrer un petit peu le type de
censure que que la Chine pratique sur
TiK ToK on a des cas de contenu qui ont
disparu de compte qui ont été fermés
parce qu'ils avaient évoqué des points
relatifs à la politique intérieure
chinoise et toujours et notamment et
c'est toujours les mêmes sujets qui
reviennent les événements tiennent à
elle-même
la question tibétaine la question des
Ouigours la question de Taïwan la
question de fallungo c'est grosso modo
ce que les Chinois appellent les cinq
poisons donc c'est les cinq menaces les
plus importantes à la pérennité du
régime communiste
et d'une manière générale d'ailleurs il
faut dire je fais une petite parenthèse
mais
les activités informationnelles et de
renseignements chinois se porte d'abord
sur ces questions là parce que
l'obsession de la Chine c'est d'abord la
fin du PCC c'est la sérénité de son
pouvoir
oui il manque le cinquième poison c'est
comme les cinq épices ouais
non enfin ça rentre pas là-dedans sauf
quand ils sont englobés dans les
dissidents dans les démocrates et covid
contestation covid n'ayez pas encore non
non 5 poisons c'est une voilà un enjeu
assez ancien c'est une rhétorique qui
est déjà assez ancienne et donc qui vise
vraiment ce qui semble de du point de
vue du PCC menacé le plus sa pérennité
voilà c'est aussi dans ce sens là que
les Chinois peuvent s'attaquer à au
modèle démocratique c'est d'ailleurs
quand ils agissent sur le contenu c'est
aussi sur ce point-là qu'ils agissent
on observe par exemple quel que soit le
support qu'il s'agisse de réseaux
sociaux de médias traditionnels
un accroissement depuis quelques mois
d'une rhétorique anti-démocratique qui
tend à affirmer que la démocratie ne
fonctionne pas que la démocratie
c'est le mensonge en général il s'atta
le modèle américain mais pas uniquement
en tout cas il tente d'affaiblir
l'alternative démocratique en montrant
les défaillances de la démocratie
américaine donc il ne cesse de ressasser
un certain nombre de cas de racisme par
exemple l'affaire Georges Floyd voilà ce
sont des cas qui sont régulièrement mis
en avant l'hypocrisie américaine
voilà le
bien sûr bien sûr il
est dans le dans le schéma de toute
façon des mesures actives donc qui est
un
une pratique soviétique forgée par le
KGB et qui consiste à identifier dans
les sociétés cibles tous les sujets qui
peuvent créer du dissensus qui peuvent
créer des tensions sociales
donc en fait c'est pour ça que
finalement les Russes comme les Chinois
à part sur la question de la démocratie
peut-être ne véhicules pas en matière
d'informationnelle de modèles
particuliers ils essayent juste
d'affaiblir le modèle des autres donc
peu importe ce qu'ils disent finalement
ce qui compte c'est que ça affaiblisse
l'adversaire
on a eu d'autres cas de censure sur
TikTok
qui ont été révélés par une enquête du
Washington Post en 2019
et qui montrait comment
finalement les équipes de Tik Tok
étaient amenées à supprimer du contenu
qui était jugé culturellement
problématique
donc là le culturellement est
extrêmement large il faut savoir que
dans la loi sur la sécurité nationale de
2015 la culture a été ajoutée par le PCC
c'est-à-dire que la culture peut être
une menace pour la pérennité du régime
le parti pensant essentiellement au
risque que la démocratie soit importée
en Chine par la diaspora chinoise la
diaspora chinoise vivant dans des
régimes démocratiques des régimes
libéraux en venant en Chine et
susceptible d'importer ses idéaux et
donc de d'affaiblir d'affaiblir le parti
et le parti a
créé si vous voulez un label pour ça
c'est l'infiltration culturelle enfin la
même année le Guardian a révélé a eu
accès à un certain nombre de consignes
qui étaient donnés
de Tik Tok au personnel de Tik Tok et
qui voilà auquel on prescrivait
l'élimination de toute mention d'un
certain nombre de sujets dont ceux que
j'ai déjà mentionné tout à l'heure
notamment tiens amen donc on a un
certain nombre de preuves suffisamment
importantes maintenant qui montre que ce
n'est pas accidentel ce n'est pas
marginal mais qui a une pratique
systématique ou qui tend à ce
systématiser de contrôle des contenus
sur sur TikTok
autre problème qui est lié à la question
de la censure c'est celui du risque de
manipulation c'est à dire le risque que
Tik Tok soit utilisé comme un vecteur
dans la lutte informatique
informationnelle chinoise
là on revient à des pratiques qui sont
très similaires à celles qu'on peut
observer sur les réseaux sociaux
occidentaux l'idée est de diffuser voilà
des des représentations alors ça peut
être soit des représentations positives
de la Chine donc mettre en avant ces
succès
ça bienveillance le fait qu'appromeux
des relations gagnants gagnants
qu'elle tient compte des particularités
du Sud global comme elle aime elle le
rappeler régulièrement ou diffuser au
contraire des contenus informationnels
qui vont être négatifs donc on revient
aux mesures actives et qui vont essayer
d'affaiblir les sociétés cibles
il y a eu une autre un autre cas
intéressant
qu'on a moins creusé mais où Tik Tok a
été accusé aussi je sais pas à quel
point c'est étayé en tout cas
Tic-Toc a jugé utile de communiquer
publiquement sur ce sur ces questions
Tik Tok a été accusé de supprimer ou en
tout cas d'entraver la création de
compte par des Afro-Américains donc pour
limiter la présence d'Afro-américains
sur en tant que créateur pendant que
utilisateur sur sur la plateforme
j'ai pas plus d'informations sur cette
dimension là mais c'est aussi une des
critiques qui a pu être informé à
l'encontre de Tik Tok alors on en vient
à une question importante quels sont les
données qui sont collectées par TikTok
donc j'imagine que c'est une question
que vous avez pu aborder avec
des personnes qui sont plus sur la
dimension technique
j'ai toutefois listé les les données qui
peuvent être collectées par TikTok via
l'utilisation de l'application de
l'application sur sur mobile donc c'est
sans la permission de l'utilisateur sans
l'adresse Courrière son numéro de
téléphone ça date de naissance son
adresse IP bien sûr les contenus du
presse-papier les frappes sur le clavier
lors de l'utilisation de l'application
au moins peut-être même en dehors de
l'application de l'utilisation de
l'application le type d'appareil utilisé
et avec l'autorisation de l'utilisateur
avec plus ou moins de capacités de
contrôle en fonction du modèle de de
mobilité la liste de vos contacts
le micro et la caméra
la bibliothèque de photos la
géolocalisation
et voilà donc ça c'est la liste des des
données dont on sait que Tik Tok est
capable de les collecter et qui donc
sont vraisemblablement
peuvent être en tout cas transmises aux
parties sur cette question
puisque c'est une question très sensible
qu'est-ce que TikTok transmet aux
parties il faut en fait la question elle
est très vite
résolue une fois qu'on a compris que
aucune société chinoise ne peut tenir
tête aux parties c'est juste impossible
le système ne le permet pas d'abord
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une loi sur
le renseignement et une loi sur le
contres espionnage
donc de 2014 et de 2017 qui
autorise les services de renseignement
chinois a demandé à toute entreprise
chinoise de transmettre les données dont
elles dispose sur des individus ou des
personnes morales
mais soyons clairs les services de
renseignement chinois le faisaient déjà
avant que ces lois ne soient promulguées
et il ne viendrait à l'esprit d'aucun
entrepreneur chinois qu'il s'agisse
d'une entreprise publique ou privée de
tenir tête au ministère de la Sécurité
d'État donc il faut partir de l'idée que
aucune entreprise
ne peut conserver des données
contre la volonté du des services de
renseignement chinois qu'il s'agisse du
ministère de Sécurité d'État ou du
ministère de la Sécurité publique
cela étant dit
les données dont on parle sont une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan des données
captées par la Chine ça il faut aussi en
avoir conscience c'est-à-dire que c'est
louable de s'attaquer à la question des
données que Tik Tok peut collecter mais
ça ne représente qu'un très faible
pourcentage de la masse de données
captées par la Chine aujourd'hui si on
parle serait ce que des Etats-Unis qui
est l'acteur le plus impliqué dans cette
opposition à Tik Tok aujourd'hui
les opérations cyber menées contre
l'office du management du personnel
américain ou
l'entreprise Equifax donc qui est une
société de de
régulation des du crédit à la
consommation à offert et on pourrait
ajouter le l'opération de hacking des
données de la chaîne total Marriott
avec ces trois opérations cyber la Chine
détient des millions de données sur des
individus américains sur à peu près la
moitié de la population américaine
ce qui est beaucoup plus large et des
données beaucoup plus précises puisque
c'est aussi des données financières
c'est des données sur qui a fait une
demande
de d'habilitation au secret défense aux
États-Unis voilà donc des données
beaucoup plus précieuses pour les
services chinois que celles offerte par
TikTok donc je suis pas en train de dire
bien sûr que c'est pas important qu'il
faut pas s'en occuper mais c'est qu'une
toute petite part des données qui sont
captées par par la Chine aujourd'hui
et qui représente à la fois des données
exploitables dans le cadre d'opération
de renseignements c'est-à-dire que quand
on cible une personne en particulier on
peut récupérer énormément de données sur
sa situation financière sur quel type de
d'habilitation il a demandé
voilà quel est son
ton portefeuille éventuellement
ce qu'il a même suivi une thérapie ou
des choses comme ça on peut apprendre
énormément de choses
dans le cadre d'une opération de
renseignements humains donc une personne
qu'on va recruter ensuite pour pour
obtenir des du renseignement ou dans le
cadre de programme de
[Musique]
Big Data et d'intelligence artificielle
donnée qui sont utilisés pour nourrir
ses intelligences artificielles mises en
place par pk
très rapidement pour finir
les autres questions qui se posent
peut-être moins brûlante mais qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est celle du pouvoir du
PDG de TikTok qui semble relativement
faible au regard de la société mère by
dance
autre question qui a pu être
évoqué c'est celle du lobbying on
observe depuis 2019 une
accroissement
très important du budget consacré au
lobbying par TikTok c'est à dire que il
est intéressant de constater enfin il y
a plein d'autres entreprises qui font du
lobbying sans que ce soit forcément
significatif mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que Tik Tok c'est plus attaché à
accroître ses moyens de lobbying puisque
aujourd'hui ils sont bien supérieurs à
ce droit ouais par exemple
plutôt qu'à répondre aux inquiétudes des
gouvernements ou des utilisateurs quand
elles ont été
quand elles se sont manifestées enfin
dernier point que vous évoquiez
également dans dans vos questions c'est
celle d'une éventuelle volonté de la
Chine ou de Tik Tok disons d'abêtir les
sociétés cibles les populations la
jeunesse qui utilise qui utilisent Tik
Tok alors bien évidemment
impossible à vérifier en l'état on n'a
pas assez de données pour voilà il nous
faudrait des études beaucoup plus
poussées
ce qui est certain c'est que
le fonctionnement même de l'algorithme
de Tik Tok fait qu'il y a captation de
l'attention qui est beaucoup plus forte
que dans sur les autres plateformes à
tel point que les autres plateformes
s'en inspirent aujourd'hui
donc cette captation de l'attention fait
que Tik Tok devient plus dangereux
maintenant est-ce que ce que
l'algorithme pousse comme contenu et
orienté par Pékin ou simplement par vos
choix les choix des utilisateurs ça
c'est enfin on l'état on ne sait
toujours pas
bien évidemment on ne peut qu'être
étonné des différences de contenu entre
drowin donc la version chinoise et Tik
Tok la version internationale
certains l'ont déjà signalé la version
chinoise comporte du contenu beaucoup
plus éducatif par ailleurs le
gouvernement chinois a limité le temps
d'utilisation de de cette application
pour les pour les citoyens chinois je
crois que c'est 40 minutes par jour
ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas chez nous bien
qu'on pourrait réfléchir à ce type de ce
type de contrainte pour ce type ce type
d'acteur donc je m'arrête là pour cette
présentation liminaire et je dis tout à
fait prêt à répondre à vos questions
merci Monsieur on va commencer par les
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup de d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation je ne connaissais pas
votre rapport d'octobre 2021 je m'en
veux d'ailleurs
je l'ai découvert il est
particulièrement éclaire pour tout vous
dire il fait froid dans le dos
évidemment une porte pas que je suis sur
Tik Tok il porte sur la stratégie
d'influence chinoise en général il est
particulièrement éclairant je le
recommande tout nos collègues sénateurs
il est disponible librement sur Internet
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faudrait le
recommander dans toutes les écoles de
sciences politiques une école de guerre
etc peut-être d'ailleurs peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il est qu'il est utilisé
alors ma première question elle est dans
d'autres générales il se rapporte a été
publié il y a un an et demi donc
je voudrais vous demander depuis un an
et demi Tik Tok a évidemment explosé au
niveau de son nombre d'utilisateurs
d'ailleurs vous disiez tout à l'heure
essentiellement des adolescents et des
mais en fait de plus en plus on a
l'impression que c'est un réseau social
qui va prendre la place de beaucoup
d'autres plateformes et qui petit à
petit s'intéresse s'adresse de plus en
plus est utilisé de plus en plus par des
adultes donc par rapport à ce que vous
aviez écrit en octobre 2021 quels sont
pour vous les faits marquants est-ce que
la comment dire les choses se passent
exactement se passe comme avant ou
est-ce que
la croissance du réseau introduit
d'autres fonctions dans le domaine de
l'influence etc qui n'existait pas
encore ou à développer des une partie
des fonctions la deuxième ordre de
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est qu'il s'agit sont dans les deux
sens je dirais d'un côté il y a collecte
de données de l'autre il y a production
ou poussée de contenu donc c'est à
double sens le premier sens les
collectes de données
vous nous avez expliqué tout à l'heure
et c'était évidemment
clair pour nous que la loi chinoise qui
oblige à déférer à toute demande
sérieusement la loi chinoise qui impose
dans la dans le
comité de direction dans la direction de
Biden d'avoir une cellule du Parti
communiste chinois montre bien qu'il
évidemment aucune
échappatoire aucun sympatoire pour pour
les dirigeants de by dance par rapport
aux parties communistes chinois mais les
dirigeants de Tik Tok lorsqu'ils sont
interrogés aux États-Unis ou en Europe
nous disent nous ne sommes pas by dance
nous sommes des TOC nous sommes une
société
immatriculer ailleurs d'ailleurs en ce
qui concerne by dance
le monde et non pas bail d'un signe de
ce lieu est immatriculé aux îles Caïman
je suis pas sûr que dans leur réponse de
soi quelque chose qui leur confère
beaucoup de
un gros avantage
mais il nous disent
voilà
d'abord nous ne déferrons pas aux
demandes du Parti communiste chinois
deuxièmement jamais bydens n'a eu de
demandes particuliers chinois
troisièmement s'il devait l'avoir demain
il ne le ferait pas en ce qui concerne
bidens
c'est même pas la peine de
discuter s'il s'agit d'un mensonge ou
non en ce qui concerne Tik Tok je crois
pour ma part que c'est exactement la
même chose je voudrais vous demander
quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
et sur le
je m'arrête là pour le moment dans
l'autre sens sur la production de
données vous avez écrit dans votre
rapport
les dirigeants de Biden donc là je parle
de désinformation ou de censure les
dirigeants de bails ainsi compris le
pdgiani ont déclaré officiellement qu'il
s'assurerait que leur produit servirait
à promouvoir le programme de propagande
du PCC là il répondent non pas à nous
mais au Parti communiste chinois ils ont
clairement indiqué que la ligne du parti
devait être intégrée dans les
applications de l'entreprise jusqu'au
niveau de l'algorithme
ainsi en 2018 une application de partage
de blague développée par la compagnie a
été supprimée le produit s'est égaré
publié un contenu qui va à l'encontre
des valeurs fondamentales socialistes à
expliquer
a depuis recruté 4100 sœurs
supplémentaires et investit beaucoup
d'argent pour développer un algorithme
intégrant ces valeurs fondamentales
socialistes
je voulais vous demander quel est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
un algorithme enfin si vous avez une
idée de ce que veut dire un algorithme
intégrant ces valeurs fondamentales
socialistes et bien évidemment en termes
de production de contenu quels sont les
répercussions
et puis je terminais j'ai d'autres
questions
je vais laisser parler mais mes
collègues
vous avez parlé presque en terminant
répondu la question sur la bêtise
[Musique]
sans faire de sans parler de Parti
communiste chinois cette fois-ci mais
c'est il est certain d'ailleurs le
président de la République l'a dit
lui-même que c'était une entreprise
d'une netteté confondante un
amortissement etc donc je pense pas
dévoiler grand chose en disant cela
mais vous avez
dit que pour le savoir exactement pour
pouvoir le déterminer exactement il
faudrait pouvoir comparer le produit en
détail le production de doing est celle
de Tik Tok alors sans sans le le
comparer en détail mais comme vous êtes
une des rares personnes que l'on va
interroger qui parle chinois et que vous
avez sans doute visité l'un et l'autre
on parle de différents évidentes par
exemple celle de de la coupure de
l'appli au bout de 40 minutes pour les
pour les Chinois celle de contenu
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus pédagogique est-ce que
[Musique]
par une visite par une simple
fréquentation et non pas par la
détermination des algorithmes est-ce que
par une simple visite vous voyez un
certain nombre de caractéristiques très
très
différente
entre douines et étiquet et l'étiquet
toc des autres pays
merci Monsieur rapporteur
alors depuis la publication du raport on
n'a pas noté de transformation radicale
en tout cas de de Tik Tok en tout cas
des opérations informationnelles
chinoises via TikTok
on note en revanche
une transformation des opérations
informationnelles d'une manière générale
une évolution de ces opérations qui
globalement suivent la ligne qu'on
appuie identifier dans dans le rapport
avec un durcissement croissant de ces
opérations c'est à dire que la dimension
coercitive agressive de ces opérations
de plus en plus manifeste
ces opérations sont également de plus en
plus sophistiqués
sophistiqué ça veut dire que
auparavant
quand on identifie on tombait sur une
voilà du contenu manipulé contenu
informationnel manipulé c'était il nous
fallait à peine quelques minutes pour
identifier que c'était du contenu
manipulé et pour remonter jusqu'à un
opérateur chinois un acteur chinois ça
devient de plus en plus difficile en
tout cas ça nous demande de plus en plus
de temps c'est plus fin il y a plus
d'intermédiaires de plus en plus
d'acteurs qui ne sont pas des acteurs
qui appartiennent à l'appareil du parti
état donc ça peut être des acteurs
chinois mais qui n'apparaît qui
n'appartiennent pas à cet appareil du
parti état donc c'est déjà un peu plus
difficile
de remonter et puis il y a des acteurs
qui sont des des non chinois donc des
acteurs locaux des sociétés ciblées
alors c'est très fort par exemple sur
Youtube ça on le voit très bien
d'évoluer sur Youtube où il y a des
comptes alors soit des comptes créés
par les Chinois eux-mêmes et de manière
plus subtile des comptes qui existent
déjà qui fonctionne bien qui sont popul
Aires et que les Chinois vont tenter
d'acheter qui vont payer vont payer les
producteurs les amis et les créateurs de
contenu pour qu'il diffuse du contenu
favorable à la Chine ou défavorable à
leur cible
donc ça c'est ça c'est une évolution
très nette et très rapide
ils apprennent vite
[Musique]
après bien sûr les Chinois n'ont pas
tout à fait la même stratégie que les
Russes il sont beaucoup inspirés des
Russes mais leur stratégie reste en
partie différentes les Russes mises en
beaucoup plus sur la qualité leurs d'une
manière générale leurs opérations
beaucoup plus subtiles pas toujours mais
en moyenne disons
les Chinois mise en plus sur la quantité
par exemple depuis à peu près 2-3 ans
les contenus rediffusés
les contenus produits par q-un aux
États-Unis et rediffuser sur les réseaux
sociaux le sont plus souvent par la
Chine que par la Russie c'était pas le
cas par exemple
il y a quatre ou cinq ans aujourd'hui
les chinois sont plus actifs que les
Russes en matière de diffusion des
théories du complot information
manipulées etc par les réseaux qui ont
un nom aux États-Unis donc il y a une
stratégie qui est quand même basée sur
sur le quantitatif quitte à
diffuser des produits beaucoup moins
sophistiqués parce que il s'appuie aussi
sur un certain nombre de d'avancées des
sciences cognitives par exemple on sait
aujourd'hui que plus on est exposé à une
information même si c'est une
information fausse plus le cerveau a
tendance à croire à cette information
donc c'est pas tant là enfin c'est pas
seulement la qualité de l'information
qualité de son de la manipulation de
l'information si vous voulez mais tout
simplement le degré auquel vous êtes
exposé à cette information
donc donc ça les Chinois en tiennent
compte dans leur dans leur
opérations informationnelles de la même
manière bien évidemment il y a c'est
c'est ces opérations informationnelles
font sens entre elles elles sont liées
entre elles et donc on renvoie de l'une
à l'autre par exemple dans le rapport on
a évoqué la question de
l'opération
appelée infection 2.0 donc autour de la
covid 19 et la volonté des Chinois de
faire croire que les États-Unis a fait
fabriqué le virus du Sark of 2 ils ont
ciblé dans cette opération une base qui
est la base de Ford détruits aux
États-Unis et c'est la base qui avait
déjà été ciblée par le KGB en 1983 dans
le cas de l'opération infection et donc
cette base avait été accusée d'avoir
fabriqué le virus du sida pour décimer
les populations afro-américaines et gay
aux États-Unis
le fait que les Chinois utilisent un
certain nombre de référents qui sont des
référents puissants
des théories du complot montre que la
sophistication n'est pas toujours utile
puisque en mettant quelques mots clés
quelques quelques référents clés et bien
on n'a pas besoin de plus de
sophistication que ça ça suffit à faire
sens et à renvoyer à un imaginaire
puissant du complot
en l'occurrence américain donc pas de
changement majeur ou en tout cas pas de
changement spécifique à TikTok mais
d'une manière générale une
sophistication croissante une
opérations qui sont de plus en plus du
coup clandestine avec de plus en plus
d'intermédiaires y compris locaux et
donc pour l'instant le problème on est
pénalisé par l'absence de travaux en
profondeur sur TikTok donc il faudrait
ça va venir puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent maintenant sur les
opérations d'influence chinoise et donc
on aura vraisemblablement bientôt des
études fines sur voilà le nombre de
fauconstes ce qu'il diffuse exactement
etc ça viendra sans doute assez assez
rapidement
sur la question du collecte et contenu
alors une petite précision les cellules
du parti il y en a dans toutes les
entreprises c'est pas propre pratique
toc
cela étant dit
le degré d'indépendance est plus ou
moins important c'est-à-dire que pendant
très longtemps il y a tout un tas
d'entreprises qui ont été assez
tranquilles à partir du moment où elle
donne l'impression de respecter les
grandes lignes fixées par le Parti
communiste dans l'application elles sont
relativement indépendantes et le les
membres du comité enfin de la cellule du
parti dans les entreprises ne va pas
toujours vérifier dans le détail ce qui
se passe voilà
mais le contrôle croissant depuis deux
ans à peu près sur les entreprises du
secteur des nouvelles technologies fait
que c'est de plus en plus difficile pour
ces entreprises d'avoir vraiment une
pratique commerciale qui soit totalement
indépendante du contrôle du parti
[Musique]
oui Tik Tok a dit qu'il n'avait jamais
obéi à une demande de ce type voilà de
transmettre des informations sur les
utilisateurs à l'étranger c'est faux
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure ou en tout
cas peut-être qu'ils n'ont jamais
transmis d'informations mais ils ont
autorisé l'accès à leurs informations
aux personnel de by dance qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais on joue
sur les mots puisque la conclusion le
résultat est identique c'est la
possibilité pour Biden c'est d'avoir
accès aux informations des utilisateurs
non basés enfin des utilisateurs de Tik
Tok
sur le sur le contenu bien évidemment
oui qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des
valeurs socialistes qu'une application
soit à l'image voilà au caractéristiques
chinoises c'est très clair en fait c'est
la nécessité pour toutes ces entreprises
de se conformer à l'idéologie du parti
aux grandes lignes fixées par le parti
lignes qui sont de plus en plus sévères
de plus en plus strictes
et qui impose d'autres entreprises
de diffuser du contenu qui se conforme à
la fois à l'idéologie sur un plan
politique mais aussi sur le plan des
mœurs donc voilà pas de contenu à
connotation sexuelle
pas de contenu irrespectueux vis-à-vis
de certaines parties de la population
voilà dire que les contrôles sont
beaucoup plus forts que ce que nous nous
imposons
à nos plateformes ou y compris au
plateformes type Tik Tok
donc voilà ça répond en partie aussi sur
les caractéristiques du contenu
je crois que là la Chine voilà elle a
intérêt enfin en tout cas
sur Tik Tok à l'intérêt à diffuser du
contenu qui va à la fois et c'est ça qui
est qui différencie aussi bien que ce
qu'il faut prendre faudrait peut-être
nuancer un petit peu mais en tout cas de
manière un peu superficielle ce qui
différencie la Chine et la Russie c'est
que alors que la Russie tend à diffuser
plutôt du contenu qui est d'une qui est
la plupart du temps négatif donc qui
cible des faiblesses de la société viser
et les montants épingles les diffuses
très largement etc
il suffit de voir ce que fait Wagner par
exemple sur sur l'influence française en
Afrique et on en a une idée assez claire
même s'il est spécialistes de la Russie
montrent que depuis quelques temps et
peut-être d'ailleurs influencé par la
Chine les Russes recommandent à
s'intéresser à la diffusion d'une image
positive de la Russie donc c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il faudrait un petit peu
nuancer en tout cas la Chine elle essaye
de tenir toujours les deux bouts avec
diffusion de contenu positif sur
elle-même
sur sa politique sur son respect
des pays en voie de développement du Sud
global etc
sur sa puissance technologique
industrielle sportive ce que vous voulez
et à la fois du contenu négatif à
l'image des Russes du coup pour diviser
les sociétés ciblées pour voilà créer du
dissensus etc
sur les différences oui
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
oui il y a des différences manifestes
sont celles que vous avez mentionnées
donc des contenus beaucoup plus qui sont
expliqués parce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire c'est c'est politique aussi
liée au bonheur en Chine qui impose
voilà et et le contrôle sur les
pratiques addictives donc là le sitting
a imposé un contrôle des réductions des
pratiques addictives c'est pour ça que
aussi les pratiques de jeux vidéo ont
été profondément réduites
limitée que les cybercafé ou avant
envoyer des adolescents passer leur
journée leur nuit sont beaucoup plus
contrôlés
donc c'est c'est en partie pour ça
ce que l'on ne sait pas c'est à quel
point le fait de pousser du contenu qui
tend à abêtir les utilisateurs est une
stratégie de la Chine ou pas est-ce que
c'est une conséquence de la néfaste de
l'algorithme seulement
parce que a priori on est encla à penser
que l'algorithme il a été surtout conçu
pour
pour faire du profit c'est ça l'intérêt
de de la société de Tik Tok avant tout
et de bindance pas pour diffuser des
fausses informations etc maintenant la
plateforme ayant du succès elle
intéresse forcément les services chinois
qui eux peuvent être tentés de diffuser
du contenu via cette plateforme à quel
point c'est fait en accord en
coopération avec Tik Tok c'est difficile
de savoir
j'ai une ou deux questions à vous poser
mais j'en profite pour dire à mes
collègues qui signalent s'il y a des
prises de parole où il y a eu tout le
monde très bien c'est noté
je me fais un peu l'avocat du diable
mais pour vous amener à
préciser le les choses vous avez
commencé par dire que finalement les
données qui étaient collectées sont en
tout cas la nature des données n'était
pas pire que sur d'autres plateformes et
même dit que peut-être qu'ils ont
collecté un peu moins que Facebook
enfin que meta vous avez évoqué aussi
vous avez fait un distinguo entre les
données qui sont collectées sans
autorisation en faisant non date de
naissance bon
c'est pas un scoop sans doute que les
uns les autres je n'avais pas de compte
tip-top j'en ai toujours pas mais je
suis quand même allé voir ce que c'était
quand on s'inscrit on est bien obligé de
donner sa date de naissance etc donc il
y a rien des pas de temps dans vous
pouvez mentir
oui enfin non jamais moi je suis pas là
personne il y a personne viendra
contrôler ça derrière mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on peut bien se
douter quand on s'inscrit dans toute
bonne foi que tout ça est collecté et ce
qu'on fait sur l'ensemble des
plateformes donc le problème c'est parce
qu'on met à disposition c'est
l'utilisation qui peut en effet mais ce
que vous pourriez nous nous repréciser
de votre point de vue du point de vue de
quelqu'un qui connaît la culture
chinoise ce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans votre audition
finalement de dire que un état fait
attention pour le dire gentiment au
contenu qui sont disponibles et ce qu'on
accepte de fournir à la population c'est
pas de pas de données pornographiques
bon bah enfin en France non plus
normalement sur une heure de grande
écoute sur des chaînes de télévision
contre les par la com il y a pas de
contenu pornographiques donc sans
vouloir faire de relativisme ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser finalement entre
meta ou TikTok dans les pays respectifs
où c'est diffusé est-ce que finalement
ça n'est pas simplement lié à la culture
locale encore une fois sans faire de
relativisme et qu'il y a des choses
qu'on n'a pas envie de laisser la vue de
d'enfants ou de gens qui j'ai dit que je
me faisais l'avocat du diable mais non
bien sûr est-ce qu'il y a une différence
profonde ou quelle est la nature de
cette différence puisqu'il y en a une
entre les problèmes qu'on rencontre avec
par exemple Cambridge Analytica
ou ce qu'on peut supposer ce qui sera
fait par l'État chinois des données
TikTok ou encore sur le fait que d'un
côté on a un contrôle qui est
probablement après qu'on a vu ce que
l'algorithme pouvait donner on a un
contrôle sur ce qu'on a envie de de
comment dire de voir mis à disposition
et d'un autre côté des plateformes qui
au contraire par souhait par souci du
profit laisse filer ils peuvent créer
des difficultés parce que c'est presque
le problème inverse avec facebook donc
là je me disais je me fais l'avocat du
diable mais c'est que pour vous puissiez
nous exposer ça en nous expliquant
pourquoi ça peut fonctionner dans la
culture chinoise
et la question additionnelle c'est cette
façon de
comment dire de contrôler les contenus
est-ce que c'est tenable à long terme
parce que la question de l'addiction de
l'algorithme sur la réaction neuronale
et ce que les neurosciences nous
apprennent depuis quelques années ce qui
est une différence de fond entre un
entre un chinois et un Occidental une
fois que l'algorithme est bien fichu et
qu'on est dessus ce que la limitation à
40 minutes est-ce que la limitation des
jeux vidéo en ligne c'est tenable à long
terme pour le pouvoir chinois
ce qu'au bout d'un moment ceux qui
pensent pouvoir infinie et faire une
utilisation avec un profit étatique ou
politique finissent pas par se prendre
les pieds dans le tapis
est-ce que vous pouvez préciser ce que
vous entendez par culture du coup est-ce
que vous voulez dire est-ce que ça
marche parce que la culture chinoise
fait que l'utilisation n'est plus
vertueuse
je crois pas
c'est plutôt le contrôle c'est à dire
que c'est un certain nombre de
prescriptions du parti qui font que
la l'orientation de la plateforme
a pris une toute autre direction que que
chez nous si on avait le même type de de
critères imposé nos plateformes sans
doute que l'orientation serait peut-être
similaire à celle de Dorine
en revanche si je reprends la question
sur
finalement
si collecte pas enfin pas plus de
données que facebook du coup il y a la
question de
d'affaires comme ça de Cambridge United
par exemple
oui donc bien évidemment
d'après certaines études du coup meta
Facebook
collecte plus de données dans certains
cas ces données peuvent être utilisées
contre nos intérêts c'est bien évident
mais ce qui fait la différence majeure
c'est que mais elle n'est que là c'est
la nature des régimes politiques et du
coup la nature des régimes politiques
fait que l'utilisation de des données
peut être très différente en Chine
et aux Etats-Unis même si aux États-Unis
peuvent être utilisés contre nos
intérêts essentiellement économiques
mais parfois même un peu imaginer
politique dans lequel la Chine c'est
très manifeste et c'est beaucoup plus
fort
par ailleurs il y a peut-être une
différence qu'il faut mentionner aussi
c'est la question de la quand on
réfléchit finalement à ce que font les
Chinois on peut toujours se poser de la
question de la réciprocité dire pourquoi
Twitter n'est pas autorisé alors bon
nous on n'a pas de plateforme de ce type
en France ou ni même en Europe mais mais
en tout cas c'est la question que les
Américains devraient poser c'est à dire
pourquoi on devrait tolérer TikTok si
vous vous ne tolérez pas Twitter
Facebook etc en Chine nous on est prêt à
le faire mais faites la même chose et on
pourrait
étendre la comparaison à tout un tas
d'autres tout un tas d'autres questions
y compris la présence et le travail des
journalistes dire les médias chinois
travaillent de manière totalement libre
en France
pourquoi c'est si compliqué pour nos
journalistes qui sont parfois harcelés
parfois on subisse des refus de visa
peuvent être embêtés par la police sur
place voilà
parfois ça va beaucoup plus loin peuvent
être aussi poursuivis devant la justice
les chercheurs aussi d'ailleurs il y a
une chercheur française qui a poursuivi
parfois
oui insulter voilà donc
à chaque fois je pense ce qu'il faut
remettre en avant avec des limites parce
que nous vivons dans un régime
démocratique et bien sûr on va pas
adopter les mêmes pratiques que qu'un
régime autoritaire mais on peut leur
renvoyer le fait que
en tolère des choses qu'il ne tolère pas
et peut-être là il y a matière à
négocier disons en tout cas les alerter
sur sur ce genre de
d'asymétrie d'une manière générale la
Chine on est souvent dans des relations
asymétriques ce qui fait qu'on aurait
intérêt à négocier le plus largement
possible quel que soit le sujet même si
je parlais essentiellement de questions
politiques
on aurait intérêt à négocier le plus
souvent possible elle est à l'échelon
européen et pas par l'échelon national
pour pour peser plus lourd
est-ce que la limite est tenable
c'est une question quelle est
extrêmement difficile de répondre
il y a quelques
temps
une vingtaine d'années les Chinois
avaient introduit des élections au
niveau local et au niveau du village et
on se demandait si c'était pas le vert
dans le fruit et que finalement par un
processus de c'était des vrais élections
donc tout le monde pouvait se présenter
alors il y avait qu'un parti autorisé
c'est le parti communiste mais on
pouvait être candidat hors partie
et est-ce que ça allait pas entraîner un
processus de politisation voilà des
ruraux et puis par par contamination
capillarité ça allait remonter la chaîne
la chaîne de de étatique bon finalement
pour l'instant en tout cas il y a eu
rien de tel c'est rester globalement ce
contrôle ça a même profité aux parties
en un sens pendant un moment puisque ça
a renforcé sa légitimité
donc on peut se demander voilà donc
c'est tout à fait possible que le parti
arrive ce qui caractérise le Parti
communiste chinois c'est quand même sa
très grande ductilité c'est une capacité
à s'adapter quand même aux situations
alors plus ou moins bien sûr mais
la Chine c'est pas forcément un régime
dans lequel
toutes
expression d'un mécontentement et et
réprimer il y a les manifestations qu'on
a vu il y a quelques semaines
liés aux règles de contrôle
de la pandémie
c'est alors même si elle était d'une
ampleur un peu nouvelle ce type de
manifestation de de
contestation même de manifestations qui
les gens vont manifester dans la rue
sans même s'ils disent pas exactement
pourquoi c'est pas très clair ou qui
vise qu'ils accusent les cadres locaux
pour permettre en cause l'hégémonie du
PCC etc les citoyens chinois savent très
bien faire ça
c'est toléré en partie c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une quand même une dose de
contestation de à la marge qui est qui
est toléré
tout ça pour dire que le parti est
beaucoup plus subtil que il peut donner
l'impression parfois et donc il est
peut-être capable de
réussir à tenir les choses avec avec
cette application mais
ce qu'on note aussi depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de steamping c'est une
rigidification du système c'est à dire
que cette ductilité elle était vraiment
caract
pratique du des dirigeants précédents
surtout routine Town et même giant un
petit peu et steamping a eu tendance à
casser un petit peu ces mécanismes
d'ingénierie du consentement si vous
voulez et aujourd'hui
la répression est beaucoup plus forte le
contrôle est beaucoup plus fort
l'idéologie est revenue à prix une place
plus importante même si c'est beaucoup
un jeu c'est un maquillage c'est de la
rhétorique mais elle est là malgré tout
et cette rigidification fait que le
système est sans doute en même temps
plus fragile c'est-à-dire que vous avez
plus de chance d'être réprimé pour des
activités jugées
hostile au PCC mais en même temps il me
semble que le PCC est beaucoup moins
capable de serrer beaucoup moins capable
de résister à un mouvement de
contestation d'ampleur aujourd'hui en
Chine que peut-être sous routine temps
d'abord parce qu'il a cassé un certain
nombre de mécanismes voilà de de
consentement
du de la population et aussi parce qu'il
est beaucoup plus aveugle sur ce qui se
passe au niveau local c'est-à-dire que
il y a un certain nombre de mécanismes
qui permettaient de la remontée
d'information jusqu'au sommet du pouvoir
qui ont été cassés société et on a
affaire à un pouvoir qui est très
largement mal informé et qui ne perçoit
peut-être pas complètement ce qui se
passe
sur le terrain
merci beaucoup quelques questions et
peut-être de demande plutôt de de
précision vous avez évoqué la censure le
retrait de certains contenus ayant très
à des sujets bien précis vous avez
évoqué aussi l'injonction faite aux
entrepreneurs de donner remonter les
données de leurs entreprises ou de leur
client
vous pouvez vous dire très précisément
quel est le cadre législatif chinois à
cet endroit y a-t-il un cadre législatif
qui a été énoncé
y a-t-il une différence entre cette
injonction faite aux entrepreneurs
chinois et ce qui se passe avec les
plateformes américaines sur requête de
l'État fédéral et DSi des entreprises
qui traitent de la donnée y compris or
États-Unis doivent fournir les données
utilisées donc par les les abonnés une
autre question porte sur les comptes
y a-t-il aussi à travers les amis les
utilisateurs c'est à ceux qui ne
seraient pas abonnés à TikTok la
reconstitution de ce qu'on appelle des
Shadow profils pour se doter davantage
d'informations sur la société
occidentale en général est-ce que ce
sont des pratiques aussi avérées à votre
connaissance vous êtes un spécialiste de
la stratégie d'influence pouvez-vous
nous dire aussi s'il est plateformes
américaines je pense notamment à
Facebook pourrait faire l'objet d'un
gérance de la part de la Chine à la star
de ce qui s'est passé dans la fameuse
affaire Cambridge a été qui a été évoqué
savoir les Russes ont pu s'infiltrer et
manipuler les opinions à la faveur de
scrutin électoraux est-ce qu'une telle
stratégie est à l'oeuvre de ce que vous
connaissez exploitant les les failles de
ces plateformes
américaines et puis j'avais une dernière
question je sais pas ce que c'est un
algorithme addictif j'ai l'impression
que c'est plutôt les contenus qui sont
addictifs ou est-ce que vous pourriez
préciser
je suis pas une informaticienne j'ai pas
une spécialiste mais personne retombe
mais c'est quoi un algorithme addictif
que somme toute les les l'Instagram
Facebook ça c'est aussi très addictif en
réalité qu'est-ce qui va différencier
l'algorithme
merci
bien alors sur le cadre législatif c'est
ce que j'ai mentionné au début de mon
intervention c'est à dire qu'il y a un
certain nombre de lois qui ont été
votées par par la Chine par l'assemblée
qui
exige ou en tout cas qui impose à tout
individu ou personne moral te
transmettre les informations au service
de renseignement chinois qui pourraient
le demander mais encore une fois c'est
je pense que ça n'a pas d'importance
puisque de toute façon ils étaient
capables de le faire avant
donc bien évidemment et on peut on peut
essayer de comparer le cadre législatif
en Chine et aux États-Unis
il y a de toute façon des différences
majeures c'est que en Chine si non
seulement vous vous prendrez pas le
risque de dire non aux agents de vos
officiers de ministère de la Sécurité
d'État qui vient de vous demander des
informations sur vos utilisateurs et
et si vous n'êtes pas content du
traitement vous n'irez pas en justice
parce que parce que d'abord vous perdrez
et puis parce que les les conséquences y
compris pour votre intégrité physique
pour être catastrophique ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas aux
États-Unis donc je veux dire c'est les
deux mécanismes les deux systèmes sont
tout simplement incomparables ça veut
pas dire que le gouvernement américain a
pas accès à un certain nombre de données
etc bien évidemment il faut pas être
angélique mais mais on parle de système
qui sont complètement différents et dans
le cas du système américain vous avez
toujours la possibilité de d'aller en
justice y compris pour dire que vous
avez été
traité de manière illégale par par le
gouvernement américain
[Musique]
sur la l'infiltration
alors oui les Chinois utilisent créer
des comptes alors sur Tik Tok à quel
point on sait pas c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que on n'a
pas de de recherche
qui a été menée sur TikTok suffisamment
fine pour qu'on ait une idée précise à
la fois des des maudits opérandis et
voilà de la quantité de faux compte
manipulée par des chinois sur Tik Tok
mais il y en a vraisemblablement
après est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de créer
des faux comptes sur Tik Tok pour
récolter du de ces informations j'en
suis pas persuadé en fait je pense que
les données sont recueillies
de profil de nos abonnés à TikTok c'est
à dire l'entourage d'une famille les
amis d'une famille le réseau d'une free
comme facebook le fait oui oui
probablement probablement
ils le font probablement comme ils le
font sur les autres plateformes
dans tous les cas
les plateformes sont utilisées à la fois
voilà pour diffuser du contenu et pour
collecter des informations qu'il
s'agisse d'informations
sur des individus ou globalement sur des
segments de société ou sur des sociétés
entières
ça c'est évident même si on n'a pas
d'enquête précise qui permettrait de de
le chiffrer ou de détailler le module
operadies
et alors qu'est-ce qu'un algorithme
addictif mais la question aussi de
la dans les plateformes étrangères la
star de ce qu'on fait les rues mais
alors vous voulez dire au sein des
sociétés au sein de la société ou au
sein du réseau je vais répéter ma
question des plateformes comme facebook
on fait l'objet d'un gérance étrangère
on a évoqué l'affaire comment génétique
à clairement les failles par le réseau
social lui-même ont permis russe de
manière avérée de s'infiltrer de
manipuler des scrutins électoraux etc
est-ce que les chinois ont la même
stratégie alors ils l'ont peut-être mais
pour l'instant on n'a pas de cas
on n'a pas on n'a pas de cas qui serait
similaire à celui de Cambridge Analytica
pour les chinois mais on sait que les
Chinois s'intéressent à l'ingérence
électorale ça ils le font déjà donc
ensuite il n'y a qu'un pas à franchir
pour exploiter ce type d'outils aussi
dans le cadre de gérance électorale ils
le font de manière fin depuis longtemps
et avec vigueur à Taïwan
de plus en plus au Canada en Australie
en Nouvelle-Zélande
voilà il commence à s'y intéresser aussi
aux États-Unis
et
l'Europe reviendra l'Europe viendra donc
il faut il faut voir je pense que il
faut il faut vraiment voir ce qui se
passe d'abord à Taïwan ensuite en
Australie par exemple en
Nouvelle-Zélande au Canada comme un
petit peu l'image de notre avenir
même si bien évidemment
la nature des régimes politiques des
systèmes politiques des du des modes de
scrutin etc font que
est à unitaire état fédéraux etc
forcément les stratégies sont
différentes mais la volonté de peser sur
les élections et est évidente
et donc sur l'algorithme addictif
alors là encore une fois c'est pas ma
spécialité mais ce que semble dire les
techniciens les ingénieurs c'est que
TikTok et la plateforme la plus efficace
pour créer de l'addiction parce que
l'algorithme est mieux capable disons de
comprendre ce qui vous intéresse il
suffit que vous passiez un tout petit
peu plus longtemps sur une mini vidéo et
ça se joue en microseconde
c'est rien du tout si l'algorithme
détecte que vous avez été un tout petit
peu plus
long à passer une vidéo qui que la
précédente c'est qu'il y a au moins un
intérêt et donc elle va pousser du
contenu qui ressemble à celui-ci c'est
ça cette qualité du du de l'algorithme
qui lui permet d'être aussi addictif
bien plus efficace que ce que YouTube ou
Instagram sont capables de faire
quand ils essayent d'évaluer les
algorithmes évaluent vos goûts
même bio merci monsieur le Président
merci à vous pour déjà toutes ces
réponses quelques questions simples en
plus de toutes celles qui viennent de
vous être posées vous avez
identifié la volonté Tik Tok d'affaiblir
des sociétés cibles il a surtout été
question des Américains est-ce qu'on a
connaissance finalement d'attaque sur
des sociétés une hiérarchie de ces
sociétés ciblées par Tik Tok donc c'est
la première question la deuxième
question
Tik Tok un public assez jeune est-ce que
ce n'est pas contradictoire par rapport
finalement à la volonté de collecter un
certain nombre de données j'imagine que
ces données sur un public différent
d'entreprise de décideurs les données
seraient peut-être plus intéressantes
donc comment expliquer vous ces menaces
qu'on ressent par rapport à ce réseau et
là et finalement le public jeune qui est
visé la troisième une question concerne
ce réseau qui est en fait le seul réseau
social qui a réussi à séduire aussi bien
l'Asie l'Amérique que l'Europe et
comment vous expliquer finalement que ce
soit le seul réseau social qui a réussi
à s'implanter dans tous les pays du
monde alors que d'autres réseaux sociaux
ont bien tenté de le faire donc quels
sont les raisons de ce succès à
l'international et dernière question
dans votre rapport vous indiquez que la
direction de Tik Tok recevait
quotidiennement des directives de
modération
de la part des autorités chinoises donc
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
ces directives est-ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de cette directive
nombreuses quelles sont leurs contenus
leur fréquence là j'ai dit
quotidiennement mais
ça représente quoi en masse je vous
remercie
alors quand je parlais des sociétés
ciblées c'était pas par Tik Tok mais par
la Chine enfin par le Parti communiste
chinois
donc est-ce que ça rejaillit sur Tik Tok
difficile de le savoir c'est c'est
toujours pareil tout dépend à quel point
Tik Tok et contrôlé par le PCC donc je
pense qu'il faut là être prudent
je pense que les ce qui est de plus
inquiétant en fait c'est d'une part les
données qui sont collectées qui peuvent
être utilisées par des acteurs
étatique ou appartenant aux parties
chinois c'est une chose la deuxième
c'est du contenu qui peut être poussé
par des acteurs malveillants disons
qui sont forcément liés à Tik Tok donc
je pense que le succès de Tik Tok est
plutôt une opportunité saisie par les
acteurs de la lutte informationnelle
chinois plutôt que une vaste stratégie
mise en place par Pékin et dans la
création de TikTok etc donc
ce qui se passe c'est que
c'est le fonctionnement est probablement
assez similaire à celui des mesures
actives du KGB pendant la guerre froide
c'est à dire que vous avez des
membres des services de renseignement
des organes qui font de la
désinformation type département de la
propagande par exemple chinoise et qui
identifie des sujets qui peuvent
affaiblir les sociétés cibles donc
on va on va parler des gilets jaunes
quand il y a une manifestations en
France on va parler du mariage gay au
Canada parce que on sent que ça peut
être un sujet qui va diviser la
population ou en tout cas divisé par
exemple la diaspora chinoise et le reste
de la société la diaspora chinoise qui
est souvent un peu plus conservatrice
sur ce genre de sujet donc voilà c'est
ça qui vont faire donc il y a des si
vous voulez des des membres de ces
administrations de ces agences qui sont
responsables d'identifier les sujets qui
peuvent être exploités et ensuite on
imagine par quelle stratégie on va
exploiter les sujets en question et Tik
Tok et un des vecteurs que ces acteurs
peuvent utiliser et souvent ne se limite
pas à un vecteur c'est à dire que Tik
Tok c'est l'un des vecteurs qui va être
utilisé dans une vaste stratégie
multi multicano en fait donc on va à la
fois faire du TikTok du Twitter du
Facebook du média traditionnel
des réseaux enfin du humain par des
associations professionnelles des
associations sportives des associations
d'amitié on peut utiliser des fines des
des
maisons d'édition etc et c'est
l'ensemble de ces vecteurs qui vont être
utilisés pour diffuser un message une
représentation etc donc il faut pas
isoler TikTok de l'ensemble du du
répertoire d'action dont dispose le
parti ce qui veut pas dire non plus que
tout est parfaitement coordonné et que
les acteurs n'agissent pas forcément
toujours en très très bonne entente
certains étant même en compétition les
uns avec les autres donc c'est pas
toujours très bien coordonné mais en
tout cas les grandes lignes sont les
mêmes
et sur la question de la hiérarchie bien
évidemment il y a il y a des sociétés
qui sont ciblées en priorité
soit parce que
pour différentes raisons c'est à dire
que certaines sociétés sont
intéressantes parce que elles s'opposent
ou en tout cas elles sont perçues comme
des adversaires ou des opposants aux
parties
typiquement les États-Unis ou des rivaux
disons
à la Chine ça peut être aussi parce
qu'elles sont déjà jugées comme fragiles
et donc on va les fragiliser un peu plus
ça peut être parce que dans tel pays en
particulier la Chine a des intérêts
qu'elle veut défendre ou qu'elle veut à
croire
ou en raison de la présence de diaspora
d'une diaspora importante le fait que la
France par exemple est la plus grande
diaspora chinoise d'Europe fait qu'elle
est ciblée en particulier aussi sur ce
segment là
mais moins que l'Australie ou le Canada
qui ont des communautés encore plus
importantes et qui en plus
subissent
le fait d'être des états fédéraux qui
sont plus faciles à pénétrer pour les
Chinois puisqu'il c'est plus facile de
pénétrer les autorités locales que de
participer à des élections nationales ou
tout de suite les élus sont plus
visibles etc donc c'est des sociétés qui
sont plus facilement
pénétrables
donc sur les publics jeunes
donc c'est pas des nuées d'intérêt et ça
rejoint la réponse que je viens de faire
c'est à dire que le public jeune c'est
pas il est pas isolé du reste
c'est-à-dire que Tik Tok est privilégié
pour toucher la jeunesse mais les autres
segments de la population peuvent être
touchés par d'autres
moyens par d'autres canaux de la même
manière que quand on veut toucher la
diaspora en priorité ben on va utiliser
wechat parce que c'est ce qui fonctionne
le mieux ou ou d'autres médias voilà par
exemple les si on regarde les médias
traditionnels
vous avez c'est difficile à chiffrer
avec précision mais ils ont grosso modo
95% des médias en langue chinoise hors
de Chine sont contrôlés par le parti
si vous prenez la France vous n'avez
aucun média papier en chinois
indépendant du parti nouvelle d'Europe
est un média complètement contrôlé par
le PCC et c'est ça qui informe notre
communauté d'origine enfin les Français
d'origine chinoise qui s'informent
beaucoup alors moins les à partir de la
troisième génération c'est moi le cas
peut-être mais à ce moment là c'est
souvent
wechat qui prend le relais mais ça c'est
un vrai problème dont on parle peu bien
sûr il y a RFI qui fait un travail
formidable mais avec trop peu de moyens
et donc on laisse un segment de notre
population
être informé par la Chine y compris avec
des opérations d'appel à la à aller aux
urnes alors sans directif de vote pour
l'instant mais je pense qu'il teste il
teste les pour voir à quel point ils
sont capables de mobiliser la population
quand il s'agit de les faire voter
donc tout ça et tout ça est très
inquiétant et Tik Tok c'est qu'un
segment voilà c'est un outil qui permet
de toucher un segment particulier en
gardant l'esprit que ce segment même si
effectivement c'est des adolescents
essentiellement qui n'ont pas encore
d'activité professionnelle ils en auront
un jour donc ils auront pu être
influencé par des contenus
ils ont pu du coup avoir ils pourront
peut-être avoir une image plus positive
de la Chine que les générations
précédentes et donc c'est aussi des
stratégies de long terme
et enfin
vous aviez une question sur la dimension
mondiale oui pourquoi ça se diffuse bah
là je pense que la réponse c'est aussi
la qualité de l'algorithme qui permet de
répondre à chaque fois en s'adaptant aux
besoins et au goût des populations
locales
ah oui alors
on n'a pas on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations pour ça il y a eu
quelques fuites et donc on sait que ça
existe que ça existe ce qui n'est pas
étonnant puisque tous les médias chinois
reçoivent des des directives elles
prennent la forme souvent de liste de
mots interdits et de liste de mots ou de
sujets à promouvoir en priorité
en général ça prend cette forme là il y
a un site Internet notamment américain
qui est associé à la à l'Université
Harvard je crois et qui diffuse
régulièrement ce type de directive du
département de la propagande quand il y
a des fuites il y en a régulièrement en
fait
monsieur gâteau là
oui merci monsieur le Président écoutez
tout ça est très intéressant je diverge
un peu avec vous sur les
volontés d'influence électorale de la
Chine on aura peut-être l'occasion un
jour d'en discuter je crois qu'il y a
une autre stratégie mais je voulais
revenir un peu sur une question de fond
c'est en gros de quoi TikTok est le nom
parce que
l'objectif très clairement affiché et
très tôt c'est de devenir le premier
média jeune le premier média adolescent
dans le monde ça l'est aujourd'hui avec
plus d'un milliard d'utilisateurs
la deuxième question est de savoir
est-ce que c'est une entreprise
commerciale pas tellement on voit bien
qu'il y a des ressorts idéologiques
derrière et puis que tout ça est abrité
par le le pouvoir du régime de Pékin
mais quand on regarde le peu
d'informations qu'on a sur les recettes
publicitaires c'est pas très glorieux
c'est beaucoup plus puissant que
snapchat et ça fait pas le quart de ces
recettes publicitaires et il y a une
annonce qui a été faite par les
dirigeants de Tik Tok disant qu'ils
allaient consacrer la moitié de leurs
recettes publicitaire rétribuer les
créateurs donc je me dis on est dans
quelque chose d'un ordre différent
peut-être bien sûr de la collecte de
données sans doute du stockage parce que
quand on s'intéresse à des jeunes un
jeune qui est transgressif notamment
dans un
sur ce type de média où il y a cette
incitation dans cinq ans il a Sciences
Po dans 10 ans il est dans un cabinet
ministériel est-ce que la Chine assez
capacités de stockage de parfaitement en
tous les cas la capacité
d'identification des personnes en
fonction du comportement qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes filmés donc ce que je note
c'est la volonté alors on le voit moins
en Europe mais quand on va en Amérique
du Nord notamment quand vous allez dans
les grands
magasins qui vendent du livre les
chaînes indigo ou autre mais non vous
avez une table c'est la principale table
préconisée par Tik Tok et ça devient à
coup de
renforts publicité imprescripteur
important dans l'édition mais dans tout
un tas de domaines et moi je vois assez
bien la logique qui avait eu et qui a
toujours la Chine dans des domaines
c'est faire du dumping c'était le cas
sur un certain nombre de de matières
premières les terres rares c'est-à-dire
un moment illuminé toute concurrence
avec des prix peu élevés puis une fois
qu'on a le monopole on a un autre usage
il y a une deuxième étape quand je dis
de quoi Tik Tok est le nom je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser quand même que ça
fait partie d'une entreprise dont le but
n'est pas simplement l'abêtissement mais
pousser des gens et des jeunes à des
comportements un peu hors normes pour
pouvoir avoir peut-être demain des
capacités de pression il y a des
capacités de pression directe la censure
la capitale la capacité d'influence donc
voilà moi je crois quand même est-ce que
on n'est pas dans quelque chose qui est
plus qu'une petite partie du système je
vous l'accorde systémique d'influence
chinois mais une expérimentation
extrêmement
large importante et on va pas capter un
milliard de jeunes sur la planète avec
d'ailleurs des approches totalement
différents en ce qui concerne la Chine
intérieure et le reste du monde sans un
projet à mon avis plus politique mais
peut-être que je vous dis c'est une
panorama une paranoïa anti-totalité mais
j'y vois quand même quelque chose de
plus que XM gafam ou géant de l'Internet
j'y vois un projet peut-être plus large
et dans les déclarations qu'on lit de
certains dirigeants chinois tout ça n'a
pas l'air d'être totalement anodin
alors sur le sur les élections
on pourra effectivement en parler
ça en tout cas ça fait partie de la
stratégie ça veut pas dire que toute la
stratégie repose sur l'ingérence avec
toi mais on a des cas aujourd'hui très
bien documentés d'ingérence électorale
dans plusieurs pays occidentaux
qui montrent que c'est au moins un des
volets des des opérations d'influence de
la Chine sur
sur la stratégie globale de l'entreprise
c'est difficile à dire
moi j'essaye de
de n'affirmer que
les choses pour lesquelles j'ai des
preuves voilà quand j'ai pu collecter
des suffisamment d'éléments de matières
premières pour affirmer quelque chose je
le fais sinon je préfère être un peu
prudent la votre hypothèse est plausible
bien évidemment mais pour l'instant on
en a pas la preuve on n'a pas la preuve
que ce serait un vaste plan voilà par
ailleurs j'ai quelques doutes parce que
[Musique]
globalement
le parti est pas forcément toujours très
efficace pour mettre en oeuvre de vastes
plantes ce type
en revanche il est très opportuniste
et ça il le fait très bien c'est-à-dire
que quand quelque chose fonctionne et
qu'il peut instrumentaliser ce quelque
chose ou l'utiliser à des fins qui sont
politiques même si le projet
originellement était purement commercial
ça le parti le fait sans état d'âme et
avec beaucoup d'efficacité mais ce qui
n'est déjà pas la même chose
pour nous à la limite peu importe vous
allez me dire le résultat c'est c'est ce
qui se passe sur Tik Tok mais du point
de vue du chercheur c'est quand même
important si on veut comprendre la
nature et le fonctionnement du du régime
là où vous avez raison c'est dans la
capacité de la Chine à voir à long terme
en tout cas on l'espèce
pas systématiquement ça veut pas dire
que tout projet est un projet à long
terme il y a des projets qui sont fait
dans l'urgence sans aucune réflexion qui
ne sont pas amenées à aux pensées pour
durer mais ils sont capables de le faire
ils sont capables de le faire et je vais
vous en donner une illustration
en fait on l'a remarqué dans tout
simplement dans les opérations de
recrutement
opérations de renseignements quand on
veut quand les Chinois veulent recruter
une source
quand on a un service de renseignement
travaille sur le court terme il va tout
de suite identifier la source qui peut
disposer des renseignements dont on a
besoin l'ingénieur qui travaille chez
Thalès ou voilà imaginez ce que vous
voulez ou ou le le quelqu'un qui est
dans un cabinet ministériel ou etc
quand on vit sur le long terme on va
recruter des gens plus jeunes en misant
sur eux en espérant que peut-être un
jour ils auront des fonctions
utiles pour
pour la Chine et les Chinois font les
deux d'accord non seulement ils
recrutent directement des gens qui sont
déjà en fonction et qui disposent de
l'information dont ils ont besoin et ils
recrutent aussi à long terme et donc on
a des cas
d'étudiants il y a par exemple un cas
qui a été rendu public par le FBI parce
que
l'intérêt des États-Unis c'est qu'il
judiciarise beaucoup les cas
d'espionnage et comme il judiciarise on
a accès à énormément d'informations et
sur cette base là on peut aujourd'hui
faire une espèce de cartographie de
typologie des modes opératoires des
services de renseignement chinois et il
y a un cas par exemple qui est celui de
glendes
américain qui était parti faire ses
études à Shanghai
qui a été recruté par le ministère de la
Sécurité d'État par une petite annonce
qui cherchait un étudiant américain pour
rédiger une petite étude insignifiante
sur je sais plus quel sujet c'était
l'économie américaine ou le
fonctionnement du du régime politique
études extrêmement bien rémunéré qui a
été suivi d'une autre étude puis d'une
autre et puis la relation s'étend dans
la durée pendant plusieurs mois
la première personne au contact de
l'étudiant cède passe la main à notre
une autre personne qui est là souvent un
officier du MSE et puis et puis petit à
petit voilà les travaux deviennent plus
intéressants et à la fin que lui ont-ils
proposé et bien hop pour ta carrière ce
serait peut-être une bonne idée de
tenter le concours du Département d'État
ou de la CIA parce que donc cette
étudiant a fait il a échoué au
département d'État mais il a réussi les
les premières épreuves pour le concours
d'entrée à la CIA puis il a été invité
détecteur de mensonges donc qui est
obligatoire quand on intègre la CIA aux
Etats-Unis et là il a un petit peu
paniqué quand on lui a demandé s'il
avait déjà perçu de l'argent d'une
puissance étrangère il a dit que
finalement il était plus candidat
et il a tenté de retourner en Chine et
il a été arrêté au moment où il prenait
l'avion oui ça prêtait à prendre l'avion
voilà donc le fait que les chinois les
services de renseignement chinois soient
capables de recruter des jeunes encore
étudiants en espérant qu'ils auront un
jour des fonctions intéressantes ou même
encore mieux en les incitant en les
orientant vers ce type de carrière vers
les carrières qui les intéressent
montrent qu'ils sont capables de de
développer des stratégies à long terme
avec plus ou moins de succès mais ils
sont capables de le faire
merci parce qu'on comme on a encore une
question non non mais je t'en prie
merci ça va être une question assez
simple ce que vous avez répondu beaucoup
à ma collègue Annick billon mais c'est
pour la prolonger un petit peu sur les
ce que vous appelez les mesures actives
et sur les contenus qui sont poussés ou
les termes à promouvoir est-ce que selon
vous d'après vos connaissances une
intervention directement sur
l'algorithme de Tik Tok ou est-ce que ce
sont des plutôt des comptes qui sont des
relais de ces termes à promouvoir voilà
et est-ce que Tik Tok dans les
interventions multicano dont vous avez
parlé et plus efficace ou moins efficace
que YouTube ou Facebook sachant que
YouTube un peu modifié son algorithme
pour éliminer les fausses informations
etc donc est-ce que c'est Tik Tok qui a
un canal maintenant privilégié ou pas
alors pour l'instant ce que l'on note
c'est que les Chinois privilégient le
contenu donc
on crée si nécessaire on crée des faux
comptes et on diffuse des contenus qui
vont voilà orienter
soit créer du dissensus soit orienter
les opinions sur certains sujets
après on sait pas peut-être qu'il y a
aussi une intervention sur l'algorithme
mais là on a aucune information à ce
sujet ce qui est sûr c'est que sur Tik
Tok comme sur les autres réseaux sociaux
il mise d'abord sur le contenu
ensuite l'autre question c'était sur
oui c'est c'est difficile à évaluer déjà
parce que on
il y a ce qu'on voit et tout ce qu'on
voit pas il y a ce que les réseaux
sociaux en question veulent bien révéler
certains acteurs qui acceptent de donner
accès aux
informations
à leur API donc on peut avoir les
données on peut travailler dessus
d'autres qui refusent donc la
comparaison est difficile
et de toute façon les segments de
population sont pas les mêmes
entre Facebook et voilà une application
qui a atteint son plafond qui voilà qui
grandira plus parce que c'est c'est des
personnes plus âgées voilà donc elle est
le plus en croissance il vont la
maintenir en place jusqu'à que ça ça
meurt tout doucement mais voilà donc
c'est une population beaucoup plus âgée
que sur Tik Tok mais c'est
utile quand même c'est du coup on va pas
recueillir
on va on peut recueillir le même type
d'informations le même type de données
mais pas sur le même segment de
population donc
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la bonne
façon de procéder de comparer Tik Tok
par rapport à Twitter ou Facebook ce
qu'on voit c'est que la plupart des
États qui en ont les moyens
travaillent sur tout toutes ces
plateformes
parce qu'elles sont elles sont chacune
leur avantage leur faiblesses avant
apporté tel type de données ou faciliter
l'accès à tel segment de la population
merci on va prendre des questions
conclusives de monsieur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup de tous ces réponses je
voudrais vous aider ou trois questions
pour terminer en élargissant peut-être
un peu le sujet et on m'adressant de
façon plus générale au
directeur du domaine renseignement
anticipation et stratégie
d'influencem pas seulement sur TikTok à
la fin de votre rapport nous vous dites
ce rapport ne contient pas de
recommandations il laisse à d'autres le
soin d'en tirer les conséquences
politiques qui s'imposent et qui ne sont
évidemment pas les mêmes pour tous
vous voyez où je veux en venir vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure le problème
de la symétrie et pharante entre
l'interdiction totale des gafam et
d'autres plateformes en Chine et de
toute au même moment où les Chinois
peuvent interrer les Russes et les
autres peuvent intervenir autant qu'ils
veulent sur Facebook sur Youtube etc
et de la et en plus
le Tik Tok est aujourd'hui
d'une façon ou d'une autre liée au
gouvernement chinois et peut se
développer de la façon qu'il veut dans
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
il y a donc là eu une
asymétrie j'ai cru comprendre d'ailleurs
que dans le quand vous avez évoqué cela
à mon couvert vous la faisait remarquer
en disant qu'il faudrait peut-être s'en
occuper même si vous ne l'avez pas dit
expressément la même façon vous avez
parlé des champs de liste et des
chercheurs qui sont voilà visa demande
de visa ou refus de visa etc alors qu'il
y a des millions d'étudiants chinois
suivi mon regard pour certains d'entre
eux dans les universités européennes et
américaines de la même façon vous dites
dans votre Aqua je crois je me rappelle
plus le chiffre exact mais qu'il y avait
il y a quelques il y a quelques années
plus de 2 millions de ce que vous
appelez je crois les influenceurs à 50
centimes c'est-à-dire ceux qui ceux qui
trollent ce qui sont en permanence sur
les réseaux sociaux occidentaux et payés
par le régime chinois 2 millions
évidemment
on se dit que jamais ni la France ni
même les États-Unis ne vont faire des
choses comme ça donc ma première
question c'est cette terrible asymétrie
en matière de renseignement d'une part
est-ce que vous puisque vous dites le
rapport ne contient pas de
recommandations mais peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui un an et demi plus tard
vous pourriez suggérer quelques
recommandations et est-ce que vous
auriez quelques par ailleurs en sens
contraire quelques données susceptibles
de nous rassurer sur
sur les contre-offensifs possibles la
deuxième ma deuxième question va
justement sur ce sujet vous concluez
dans votre rapport sur la France dans
encadrer sur la France
la prise de conscience en France des
risques posés par l'influence chinoise
et vivent et croissante depuis 2019 avec
une nette accélération en 2020-2021
c'est dans ce contexte de réveil
français entre guillemets qui sont
désormais irréversibles que s'inscrit la
publication du réseau rapport en
septembre 2001
je suis pas tout à fait sûr d'être aussi
optimiste que vous
et notamment
bien entendu tout le monde ici est au
courant des dernières données qui ont
conduit la Commission européenne le
Parlement européen interdit et interdire
en urgence le l'application sur le
téléphone de leur fonctionnaire
plusieurs pays européens l'ont fait en
même temps
est-ce que
cette décision est selon vous une prise
de conscience progressive ou est-ce
qu'elle
a l'air d'avoir été simultanée
pratiquement partout est-ce que les
services de renseignement ont
brusquement découvert une réalité qu'on
ne connaissait pas et pour en revenir à
ma question sur la prise de conscience
en France
on semble bien pour le moment en tout
cas être les derniers ou en tout cas pas
les premiers à avoir tiré les leçons de
ce que nous dit la Commission européenne
qui donne beaucoup de détails mais la
moindre des choses me semble-t-il et
c'est ce que je compte demander
ce ministre du numérique en France ou à
d'autres autorités c'est avez-vous
demandé à la Commission européenne
les raisons de son geste et en faisant
ça elle ouvre une boîte de Pandore
puisque si elle estime que les
transferts de données concernent ces
fonctionnaires ou celui par le européen
évidemment qui est consciente ceux de
tous les gouvernements donc est-ce que
vous trouvez que ça c'est une sorte de
prise de conscience
qui nous qui peut nous conduire à
l'optimisme par rapport au gouvernement
français
et puis ma dernière question et c'est
assez que j'ai trouvé plutôt intéressant
c'est la conclusion de votre rapport qui
dit en définitif tout cela toutes ces
stratégies d'influence sur les réseaux
sociaux etc elle se conclut par un échec
stratégique
et vous expliquer ce qui depuis deux ans
et d'un côté le durcissement du régime
chinois et en même temps l'échec de ces
loups guerriers de ces stratégies sur
les réseaux sociaux qui font
qu'aujourd'hui la vision la
considération de la Chine dans les
études d'opinion et devenu
catastrophique et extrêmement moins
bonne qu'elle ne l'était il y a un
certain nombre d'années donc et c'est
vous qui utilisez vous et j'ai
stratégiques
vous vous dites je
j'analyse cet échec comme d'une part en
lien avec le durcissement de cuisine à
la fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
de la qu'on a assisté qui nous a permis
d'assister d'ailleurs une gestion
désastreuse du covid sans doute en
rapport avec ce document et cette
éloignement de la réalité du quotidien
de valise tout à l'heure
est-ce que c'est ma dernière question
elle est beaucoup plus générale se
durcissement est-ce qu'il annonce un
nouveau blocage après
une remarmorisation si je peux dire
entre guillemets toute proportions
gardées après
les
l'épisode de dancehawking à Houdin Tao
et qui coupait à la catastrophe
démographique que l'on connaît
actuellement en Chine entraîne une proie
une probabilité d'affaiblissement du
régime chinois à terme ou est-ce que
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
où est-ce que c'est il est très très
difficile de tirer des plans sur la
comète de ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui mais qui semble
vraiment participer à la fois en même
temps avec les déboires de son allié
russe à de vrais problèmes pour les
régimes totalitaires face aux
démocraties occidentales
il y a beaucoup de questions
[Rires]
je vais essayer de d'être synthétique
donc oui nous n'avons pas fait de
recommandations
parce que on est d'abord des chercheurs
et c'est pas c'est pas notre métier mais
si vous me posez la question je peux au
moins vous donner de trois pistes qui
sont liées d'abord à la question de la
symétrie
donc asymétrie au sens où je l'ai
utilisé tout à l'heure
c'est à dire l'absence de réciprocité et
là il ne tient qu'à nous finalement de
l'exiger
à chaque fois que c'est possible ou que
ça nous semble en tout cas nécessaire
sans que ça apporte atteinte à nos
institutions à nos valeurs c'est ce qui
est une condition bien sûr
importante
mais c'est asymétrie aussi de
connaissances tout simplement dire que
le très gros problème
que nous faisons face c'est une
asymétrie dans la connaissance de
l'autre c'est-à-dire qu'on connaît bien
moins la Chine que la Chine ne nous
connaît pour tout un tas de raisons
parce que il y a beaucoup plus
d'étudiants chinois qui viennent chez
nous que d'Ét français ou européen qui
vont en Chine parce qu'il y a beaucoup
moins de Français qui parlent le chinois
que chinois qui parle le français ou
l'anglais voilà donc on a une asymétrie
de connaissance
de connaissance des institutions etc
bien sûr mais
une connaissance surtout de la pensée
stratégique et qui concerne pas de la
France en fait même aux États-Unis c'est
un constat qui est très largement
partagé
quelque chose que je mentionne souvent
parce qu'il est assez significatif mais
l'ouvrage majeur qui synthétise qui
synthétise si vous voulez ou qui est un
peu la bible de la pensée stratégique
chinoise a été traduit pour
un ouvrage qui a 15 ans il a été traduit
pour la première fois dans une langue
occidentale l'anglais l'année dernière
auparavant on continue de mentionner
soundzo ou la guerre hors limite quand
on voulait essayer de comprendre la
pensée stratégique chinoise alors
qu'elle est extrêmement riche et qui a
une production colossale à la fois par
les militaires les diplomates les
chercheurs les films tanks il y a une
pensée stratégique qui est extrêmement
vive extrêmement dynamique et qu'on ne
connaît pas donc on ne sait pas comment
les Chinois pensent
la création informationnelle
la question l'éducation stratégique
d'une manière générale comment comment
ils se représente la guerre voilà on
sait très mal tout ça et donc ça va
amène à une recommandation évidente il
faut plus de chercheurs
plus de chercheurs spécialistes de la
Chine donc il faut plus de bourse plus
de postes dans les universités
on n'a pas on n'a pas assez de sinologue
de spécialistes de ces questions là dans
nos CNRS à iversité et puis et puis dans
les fines dans les administrations aussi
également donc on a là déjà un levier
d'action très concret et qui nous
permettrait d'être mieux armés pour pour
répondre à ces enjeux
[Musique]
dans la question sur la question de la
réciprocité il y aurait un
la tentation d'utiliser un petit peu les
mêmes méthodes que les Chinois ou les
Russes d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faut
bien sûr sans prémunir
sans préserver plutôt
parce que par exemple si nous aussi on
se met à créer des fauconstes sur les
réseaux sociaux pour diffuser des
fausses informations
dirigées contre nos adversaires et bien
on se fera prendre comme eux si les
Russes et les chinois sont en prendre
voilà donc si
en fait le cas africain il est très
intéressant parce que là je crois que
l'affaire de gossis c'est typiquement ce
qu'on peut faire c'est-à-dire que voilà
révéler ce que les Russes peuvent faire
et donc entraver leurs opérations de
désinformation ça c'est vertueux c'est
efficace
et c'est un autre portée maintenant
allez créer des faux comptes pour
diffuser voilà ça parfois on pourrait
être tenté d'utiliser ce type de méthode
comme les Chinois les Russes je pense
qu'il faut s'en préserver parce que le
résultat ce serait d'affaiblir nos
propres institutions nos valeurs
démocratiques ce que les Chinois et les
Russes cherchent à faire c'est à dire
qu'en fait on pourrait tomber dans dans
le piège qui ne nous tende autre autre
recommandation qu'on peut faire c'est de
rendre public systématiquement les
opérations qui sont détectées parce que
c'est la meilleure entrave surtout quand
ces opérations sont de plus en plus
sophistiquées et qu'elles font appel à
des intermédiaires
en France et si des Français
quelle que soit la raison décide de
soutenir une opération informationnelle
chinoise il faut le rendre public et
c'est souvent le meilleur moyen
parce que le coût réputationnel est très
important d'entraver ou d'empêcher les
Chinois d'utiliser ces intermédiaires
donc ça c'est je pense il faut le faire
de manière systématique le plus
largement possible
sur la le le réveil français la prise de
conscience oui je crois que la prise de
conscience elle est progressive
c'est pas seulement là Tik Tok c'est
c'est il y a eu je crois que la pandémie
a joué un grand rôle là dedans
parce qu'elle a mis au jour un certain
nombre de pratiques
mais c'est lié aussi tout simplement au
virage chinois c'est à dire que les
Chinois il y a que tant que les
opérations informationnelles chinoises
misées essentiellement sur la séduction
ça posait pas trop de problèmes c'est à
dire que c'est pas quatre ou cinq
instituts Confucius qui pose
véritablement un problème voilà c'est
quand ces instituts sont associés à tout
un tas d'autres moyens
qu'il a peuvent nous faire beaucoup de
mal et relève de l'infiltration et là
encore il faut faire valoir la
réciprocité est-ce que les chinois
est-ce que la Chine tolérerait que les
Alliances françaises diffusent des
fausses informations réécrivent
l'histoire parce que les si on si vous
regardez les matériaux utilisés par les
instituts Confucius pour renseigner le
chinois c'est très tendanceieux sur un
certain nombre de faits historiques donc
on pourrait là aussi leur envoyer à
cette réciprocité et dire ce que vous ne
tolérez pas ou ce que vous ne toléreriez
pas en Chine pourquoi nous ne serions
obligés de le tolérer chez nous
mais cette prise de conscience elle est
réelle je crois elle est lente elle est
progressive mais elle est réelle on en a
eu de multiples illustrations
le débat aujourd'hui sur Tik Tok c'est
juste le dernier volet si je puis dire
mais
il y a eu l'emplace la mise en place de
vigilum il y a eu un certain nombre de
rapports y compris ici
de travaux scientifiques il y a de plus
en plus de journalistes qui travaillent
sur ces questions là qui enquêtes qui
révèle des choses il y a un certain
nombre de gens qui étaient très
favorables à la Chine ou qui soutenait
la Chine dans ses opérations qui ne le
font plus aujourd'hui donc ce qui montre
qu'il y a à la fois une prise de
conscience et un coût supplémentaire à
adopter ce type de comportement
non dans cette politique des chercheurs
ou des journalistes tous les domaines
vous pensez bien particulier
dans le rapport intéressant
je pense que c'est plus voilà je pense
qu'il y a un véritable coup
réputationnel aujourd'hui
qui fait hésiter un certain nombre de
personnes qui surtout quand la
motivation n'est pas idéologique ou que
ou que la motivation
n'est pas
en tout cas que ça ne va pas jusqu'au
partage d'idées mais plutôt l'idée de
notification d'un ennemi commun c'est à
dire si vous voulez en France l'une des
chances de la Chine c'est
l'anti-américanisme
les Chinois arrivent parfois à pénétrer
certains segments justement en misant
sur l'anti-américanisme et donc il y a
des gens qui aident la Chine non pas par
amour du régime chinois non pas parce
qu'ils sont convaincus par
l'idéologie
promue par Pékin par sitting mais parce
que
ils sont tout simplement anti-américain
[Musique]
alors vous avez parlé oui donc de
l'échec stratégique et vous avez parlé
de Romains je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention
on a un durcissement du régime mais qui
n'est pas une maïsisation du régime
parce que
la maoisation du régime c'est la
mobilisation des masses c'est ça le
régime oui c'est
un régime qui est bâti alors il a une
disons qu'il a c'est un peu Janus quand
il a deux visages le régime maoïste il a
un visage qui est institutionnel qui est
qui essaye de construire l'état si vous
voulez et puis là un visage qui est
celui des mobilisations populaires
on peut penser au grand bon en avant à
la Révolution culturelle etc toutes ces
fièvres populaires c'est c'est
typiquement c'est très caractéristique
du maoïsme et et ce que fait si timing
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ça
donc bon voilà c'est une petite une
petite différence mais ça permet parfois
de de pas commettre des rares d'analyses
donc oui il y a un échec stratégique
pardon
il y a un échec stratégique en effet
comme vous l'avez rappelé parce que même
si la Chine est capable de remporter un
certain nombre de succès tactiques ici
ou là avec plusieurs opérations qui ont
très très bien fonctionné et donc qui
ont apporté des gains à court terme
sur le moyen terme disons on assiste à
un effondrement de l'image de la Chine
dans le monde
l'exemple le plus fragrance flagrant
c'est celui de la Corée du Sud il y a 20
ans
la Chine avait 69% d'image positives en
Corée du Sud on est tombé à 19%
aujourd'hui
et tout simplement parce que les Chinois
ont le Parti communiste a une posture
beaucoup plus agressive vis-à-vis de la
Corée comme elle là vis-à-vis de
l'Europe vis-à-vis de l'Amérique du Nord
etc la nuance que l'on pourrait apporter
à ce
cette évaluation
c'est les succès malgré tout que la
Chine remporte dans le sud global et là
aussi ce n'est pas on peut faire une
comparaison avec ce que je viens de dire
pour la France c'est pas par adhésion au
régime chinois mais par
antioxydantalise ou anti-américanisme
parfois ça dépend de la même manière que
les les un certain nombre de pays qui
ont
qui se laissent séduire disons par les
Russes et Wagner c'est parfois plus
parce par par rejet de la France que par
adhésion au modèle russe c'est important
parce que ça veut dire que la réponse
n'est pas forcément la même c'est-à-dire
que vis-à-vis il y a une réponse qu'il
faut apporter à la Chine on doit mettre
en place un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour nous protéger contre
ces opérations informationnelles mais
ensuite il y a une réponse peut-être
dans plus diplomatique à apporter aussi
vis-à-vis de ces pays qui se laissent
séduire par
[Musique]
la proposition de de
rééquilibre mondial que propose la Chine
ce que la Chine propose c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'un révisionnisme international
et le parti le dit très clairement si le
dit très clairement si on prend la peine
de les lire ce qu'ils veulent c'est
refonder refonder le système
international pour qu'il ressemble plus
au système chinois et qu'il défendent
mieux les intérêts de la Chine
et la l'offensive vers le sud global et
elle relève de cette de cette logique et
on doit devrait se méfier
de pas trop s'isoler nous de ce Sud
global
au risque de le voir prendre parti pour
pour Pékin regardez ce qui se passe à
l'ONU au sein du Comité des droits de
l'homme on a complètement perdu on a
perdu c'est les régimes autoritaires
aujourd'hui qui dominent les débats sur
les droits de l'homme au sein de l'ONU
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont plus nombreux
et cette rhétorique là la Chine l'avance
en permanence c'est-à-dire que même dans
le vote sur les sanctions de la Russie
pour l'invasion de l'Ukraine voilà ils
ont mis en avant le fait que certes une
majorité d'État a voté en faveur des
sanctions mais les 50 ou 45 étages et
puis exactement qui ont voté contre où
se sont abstenus représentent plus de la
moitié de la population mondiale
ça c'est un argument auquel on ne sait
pas répondre alors bien sûr c'est
rhétorique ces populations là c'est pas
les populations qui votent c'est les
gouvernements etc mais pour l'instant on
n'est pas capable de répondre à ce type
d'argumentation on le fait très mal là
c'est un enjeu colossal
est-ce que du coup ça affaibli le régime
enfin est-ce qu'il y a un
affaiblissement potentiel du régime oui
mais c'est une question à laquelle c'est
il est extrêmement difficile de répondre
on peut absolument pas dire si le régime
est sur le point de s'effondrer ou pas
mais en gardant l'esprit ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que je peux
absolument pas vous dire oui le régime
s'effondrer dans les cinq ans ou 10 ans
à venir ou non c'est impossible qui
s'effondre mais s'il s'effondre je serai
pas surpris
vous concluez par une réponse de
diplomate mais on a été très intéressé
par vos considérations de chercheurs
leur ennemi qui a précédé on a un peu
dépassé mais parce que le sujet le
commander oui voilà pas de frustration
pas d'autres questions c'est bon on vous
remercie infiniment Monsieur Merci
monsieur bonne fin de journée